what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest updates in the one
piece story we got so much to talk about
here with zorro marco king and more so
make sure to stay tuned for this one if
you do enjoy seeing these one-piece
traps reviews and want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do is
channel the pirate king within and smash
that like button if you haven't make
this the video you subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my giant and
growing one piece playlist that includes
exclusive videos on the yonko warlords
and most recently all nine mythical zone
users and their powers explained i think
at least three of those mythical zones
will probably surprise you if they do
let me know in the comments you can find
all of these videos and more in the one
piece playlist link to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all this
chapter is called the stars take the
stage a very hyped title and yes it
might be referring to the all-stars but
also to our crew stars as well for now
though let's begin at the beginning we
get a quick synopsis of where we started
this war and where we got to it started
with 5 400 samurai pirates versus 30 000
beast pirates but thanks to our side
doing well and otama's dango strategy
the disparity has shrunk big time and
the wide view is one thing but very
powerful and important individual
figures have been taken out on the b
side as well namely the flying six
members with this chapter things are
really looking good for our side yes
we're told that there is 15 minutes
remaining until the island reaches the
capital but the flying six are finished
luffy is shown stuffed with food meaning
he's pretty much ready to go again for
his next round with kaido and as we know
zoro is going to join the fighting again
soon with the help of medical science
we're on a roll people the only question
is how many more times will the tables
turn and how close are we chapter wise
to the end of this conflict we jump to
the castle interior third floor and by
the way i'm so glad we're told the
position because i would not remember if
we weren't we joined the ninja battle
between rhizo and fukurokuju we get some
comedic naruto vibes during this battle
as rhizo uses clone jutsu and fuku
fights with his earlobes that's such a
bizarre odo way of fighting and it is
reminiscent to me of how jurai uses his
hair in battle in naruto but obviously
earlobes are funnier it's so funny how
easy fuku finds out who the real one is
by simply saying he's clinging to a
ghost and then the real rhizo responds
saying are you talking about odensama
the earlobe strikes and rhizo gets
earlobe whipped i must say these are
probably the most opie earlobes i've
ever seen fuku then tells raizo that he
wasn't suited to be a ninja because he
wore his heart on his sleeves while a
ninja is supposed to be more stoic but
it looks like fuku hasn't watched naruto
or he would have realized that rhizo has
his own ninja way believe it amid the
humor though we do get a great moment
where ryzel says that the day the day of
the execution they all cried laughed and
died alongside odin thus they are all
ghosts bent on fulfilling odin's dream i
really like their code of honor and
friendship it's heartwarming and
inspiring to see we get shots of all the
scabbards some on the ground while
others are still fighting rhizo then
mentions that it's not just out of duty
that they are fighting unlike fuku they
fight because of that emotional bond
that they had with odin so rather than a
hindrance emotions and bonds can be a
source of motivation and power nothing
groundbreaking here especially for
shonen anime but i appreciate it
nonetheless rhizo goes on to say that it
doesn't matter if they die they have to
see this through to the end or they
won't be able to rest in other words if
they fail to try to carry out their
mission that would be worse than death
to them no matter if they got to keep
their lives i love to see these kinds of
manly sentiments being shared finally
rhizo tells him that tonight will mark
the end of the orochi and kaido reign
and there will be a brilliant dawn
tomorrow with momo as shogun and as we
got from last chapter momo will probably
be an adult by the morning so it
wouldn't be weird to see him take the
role on at all it's so crazy to consider
that luffy and friends may overcome my
uncle crew and even to individual yonko
but things are definitely looking good
right now knock on wood and rizal's
words are getting me even more pumped up
we also get to drop in on killer vs
hawkins it's clear that killer's on the
offensive and going through a bunch of
hawkins so-called meat shields he's
exhausted by the thought of how many he
still has thankfully hawkins says he
doesn't have any left but things take a
very interesting turn when he says
killers should consider not how many are
left but whose life is currently
standing in for the life of hawkins we
then jump to big mom vs law and kid
another very hyped matchup and against
the yonko they definitely need all of
their faculties and luck too but
unfortunately hawkins was talking about
kid and kid starts noticing that
something stabbed him so yeah now for
killer to beat hawkins it seems like
he'll have to cut down kid first albeit
indirectly this makes hawkins a very
tricky fighter obviously killer would
never kill kid so he may have to find a
way to restrain hawkins or find a
workaround otherwise hawkins may take
out killer and although killer is
definitely cool he's enough of a side
character for him to possibly be taken
out right here so you never know what's
gonna happen things could have been much
worse if hawkins didn't finally admit
that kid is his current meat shield but
he's thinking about himself and wants
killer to agonize over fighting back
this is the best way to assure his own
victory while letting killer kill kid
would not have been best for him
necessarily but it would have been the
better move for the beast pirates as a
whole as far as side fights go this is
definitely an interesting one and i look
forward to seeing what happens and how
it plays out as killer points out
hawkins is twisted and that works really
well for antagonists like him not gonna
lie then we get to the meat and potatoes
of the chapter if you will we see an
amazing panel of king and queen
absolutely towering over everyone else
in the panel people are begging marco to
help and in a pretty crazy panel he
looks to be down for the count as it
said that he's reached his limit
interestingly enough oda did say in a
question corner that marco's
regeneration has its limits and i
believe that simply means when his
stamina runs out he can't use the
regeneration anymore however the
question is if his stamina is at zero
right now or not in the meantime the
all-stars are unleashed and people
believe they're going to destroy the
whole floor pretty soon that's how crazy
destructive they are sanji tells them to
get zorro out of the way obviously he
used the loving nickname moss head
instead of zoro but there's no way that
they'll actually be taking zoro away
from the battle the reason sanji said
that is because it looked like the shot
wasn't working zoro was still in
excruciating pain in fact it's taking
longer to take effect because he's in
such bad shape it's so crazy that he'll
have to deal with double this pain
afterwards not to mention the pain he'll
accumulate during the rest of the war
it's absolutely insane and such a zorro
situation to be in i think we may have
the makings for a moment that may really
rival the famous nothing happen moment
as they're waiting for my boy zorro the
legend to heal sanji continues to kick
around queen and i love these matchups i
wasn't sure with jimbei in the picture
who sanji would be fighting but i'm glad
it worked out like this interestingly
enough king is actually worried about
zoro and tells people to find him and
finish him off because the straw hats
are trying some weird healing method
he's very machiavellian in the sense
that he wants him dealt with before he
recovers he's not just thinking oh he's
not a threat i'll deal with him easily
which i respect i like to see our straw
hats being taken so seriously by such
strong opponents it shows how far we've
come in the meantime pero sparrow is
aiming at sanji with an arrow he's
especially mad at him because he feels
like if he married pudding then they
never would have joined forces with the
beast pirates so it's not just business
but personal for pero sparrow it's funny
how he calls him a germa reject but even
funnier how he gets smacked around by
nekomamushi who has arrived to avenge
pedro i really think that this avenged
pedro storyline is hilarious i wonder if
this is just going to keep haunting pero
sparrow wherever he goes for the rest of
his life because pedro decided to blow
himself up then just as it looks like
zoro is done for because the people
carrying him are surrounded and king is
right in front of them marco comes to
the rescue the yonko commander hasn't in
fact been taken out so easily which is
quite the relief he successfully blocks
king's divine flame attack with a smile
on his face to boot then we get some
interesting dialogue where marco says he
used to hear rumors about a certain fire
conjuring race that lived on top of the
red line and calls king king of the
flames but of course marco won't be the
one to fight him to the end because he's
more here to assist rather than to hog
the spotlight as the all-stars prepare
to turn to marco again marco says he
gives and that he's done his part i like
this because a marcos still comes off as
a strong dude who wasn't defeated by
king and queen in a definitive way and b
he's allowing our main guys to take the
spotlight namely zorro easily one of my
favorite characters marco even says it's
time for the stars to take stage as
zorro comes out of the bandages and you
know he adjusted his glasses while he
was at it i love the fact that in front
of the all-stars he pretty much called
zorro and the straw hats the true stars
way back i think we all saw zoro
battling king and i love to see it
finally here we get an amazing moment
and panel where zoro and sanji attack
together side by side one kicking queen
and the other slicing king we're told
that the two wings are in action which
is hype for sanji and zorro who both
managed to keep their wing status in the
evolving crew and i just can't get over
it it's so great to see these two
fighting together side by side against
the all-stars no less kaido's two
strongest fighters the bystanders go
crazy like me as they scream the straw
hats are amazing and we get another
great moment and i know i keep saying
that but this chapter is full of them
zorro says hey curly brows if we win
this and then sanji interrupts him to
finish the thought saying i know it'll
finally be in sight luffy becoming king
of the pirates goosebumps people this is
so epic right now it's making me want to
cry tears of awesomeness we have reached
the climax of this arc where these two
will take on the all-stars and luffy is
just about to meet up with kaido again
for the last time during this war i
could not have been more satisfied with
this chapter as always let me know your
thoughts about the chapter and what
you're most looking forward to seeing
next who was your mvp i gotta go with my
boy zoro for taking the pain for
returning in such a spectacular fashion
and for cutting down king i'm not saying
king is down for long but still it was
an epic panel if i could pick two mvps
at once if that's a thing then the duo
of sanji and zorro definitely gets it
their dynamic and role in this chapter
was just amazing and that is it for this
one as always thank you so much for
joining me in discussing another amazing
chapter if you do enjoy seeing these
one-piece chapter reviews and want to
keep them coming the best you could do
is channel the pyroking within and smash
that like button if you haven't make
this the video you subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos hitting the
like button and subscribing is very
pirating energy while not doing so as
very orochi energy just saying and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my giant and
growing one piece playlist that includes
exclusive videos on the yonko warlords
and most recently all nine mythical zone
users and their powers explained like i
said at least three of those mythical
zones will probably surprise you let me
know if they do in the comments of that
video you can find all of these videos
and more in my one piece playlist link
to that is in the description and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you